okay go ahead and turn around for us
please
separate your feet
turn your toes outward
place your hands behind your back don't
move you're under arrest you understand
yes
and then come closer you can see these
hands
control the elbow first
and prioritize defending yourself not
apprehending that okay
so here so
she can't turn towards us protect our
being on the back we've got that
okay
so here first
then come down
and get the song fuel and turn it down
just enough to bring more weight towards
her heels
you're going to lose sakuyo the more you
bring it towards her body so off okay
got it
all right and again don't prioritize the
apprehension
prioritize that uh
try so here grab in front like you're
preventing her escape and turn towards
us virginia
okay
and
prioritize controlling the back position
turn towards us
okay you see that difference okay
let's do it again
now i'm going to turn around for us
please
separate your feet point your toes
outward place your hands behind your
back you're under arrest do you
understand yes do not move
elbows
down with the palm and off her person
not so much that she starts falling on
you okay just heal waiting her okay
all right
okay ma'am go ahead and turn around for
you please thank you
separate your feet for us put your toes
outward place your hands behind your
back maybe you're under arrest please do
not move do you understand yes
all right so you can see that we have
the song kill so if she starts moving
we'll point the palm down and just sit
around her butt
okay take her get her in this position
disadvantage okay
same control points
right
we're going to lose the elbow when we go
to handcuff
right and now all i have is this hand
and
she can turn towards me first of
all and she could just forcefully she
could use her legs too to walk
and yank that hand out you see
it's just my grip okay
so
what we're going to do instead is we're
going to
use controlled maintenance here so
you're going to take over my elbow hand
go ahead go inside and i'll hand the
elbow to you now once you have the elbow
that's when i can let go of this okay
so keep this all tight on her
so you're protecting the turn so try to
turn towards me you see try to turn
towards her there you go and then try to
move
okay you see that okay so now
i can take a hand out
and now i can go to the two-man coffee
boom
okay do you see how that works
okay
okay so at this point for some reason
you have
me
thinking you're higher risk
okay so we're gonna see position and
disadvantage right position disadvantage
is moving her away from her maximum
offensive potential okay
one of the ways of doing that is
controlling their high kind of mobility
man go ahead and have a seat on the
ground for me please
cross your ankles extend your legs place
your hands in your lap
don't move do you understand
okay what this position does
is it's very hard for her is tilting her
pelvis up
so it's very hard for her to control her
balance so if i have you open your legs
maybe even bend your knees
you see and then she's gonna give more
resistance here like that okay
so you'll go back into the position and
this tilts her pelvis up and it's much
easier and we're gonna go to the back
eventually because that's where our
position of advantage is okay so at some
point we know we're going to arrest this
person and we'll make our way we'll give
whatever signal we want and we're gonna
go to the around her and you want to
keep the same process
okay
go ahead and put your hands behind your
back you're under arrest do not move do
you understand these orders yes okay
we'll go in
secure the elbow
get the song kill when we're ready we're
going to do the cuffing okay
i'm going to move into this position
again
and when i'm here i have this head
control here you see i'm very tight to
her
all right
um
again can try to turn towards me and
you'll see you're controlling try to
turn towards her and you're controlling
and then we can take advantage of that
pelvis do you see if i've taken her to
more position disadvantage got it
all right so not like this
you're tight dropping all right you go
ahead get the cuffs
good and then every time you handcuff
before you let go of the hands hold the
hands please you're gonna check that
lower back for any kind of weapons okay
all right
okay so
in this case i got a higher risk
uh that i sense in you for example like
a high risk traffic stop okay
um you would have your cars positioned
right and you would have your
various assignments in this
and somebody would be
giving you voice commands what they're
going to do is they're going to bring
her away from the node and into the
gnome the gnome that we are controlling
they're going to bring her back to us
and eventually hand her off to
a handcuffing team so at first i will
duplicate the one that's given voice
commands up here and then eventually i
will be part of the handcrafting team
okay so those voice commands would be
something like exit the car go ahead
face away from us put your hands up
above your head
follow my directions do you understand
if you follow my directions i can
guarantee your safety
i want you to get down your knees
lay down
sorry we're going to continue to seek
this position of disadvantage concept so
that is move her away from her furthest
maximum offensive potential so i want
you to call back towards the sound of my
voice go
and eventually she'll pass the cars and
get to where the handcuffing team is the
handcuffing team will take over when
they get her behind the vehicle so that
you can do this handcuffing between uh
or behind converted concealment you
would then do the following go ahead lay
down your stomach
crush your ankles
place your hands out to your sides away
from your body turn your palms up keep
looking straight ahead do not move do
you understand yes
then your handcrafting team would go in
we're going to talk you through it
you're simultaneously going to do two
different things on this side you're
going to do a kimura with your knee
staying off of their torso she'll grab
the wrist and elbow bring the hand
towards the feet
ground the outward knee and
put the inboard knee into her elbow
nothing is on her person i'm gonna have
you tap out when you don't like it
to apply more pressure and increase the
shoulder impingement she would go
forward
tap okay but here she's just controlling
while
one officer is doing that go ahead and
come back off
the other member of the two-man arrest
team in this case it's the two man we
have the three man we're showing the two
men
will come in at the same time control
the feet come down and gain the songkyo
again here
again nothing's on her respiratory
system so talk for us hello
you can hear her breathing there's no
compromisation on her uh respiratory
system uh the reason i'm holding the
sakyo is if they're really strong she
tries to buck me off go ahead she's just
pulling me into this rope that is her
arm currently all right once we're in
position which means we have control of
her
that is when
we'll go to the handcuffing
this time i do the handcuffing working
from the songkill i go first
boom and then my partner will bring that
knee back past the bottom of the
respiratory system push the elbow in and
put the hand into the other tongue kill
into the cuff we always check the
smaller the back before we let go of the
hands and double cuff etc etc all right
let's get into position
what i want you to understand here is
this is not working
with a weight
okay
it's working by depositing her
do you understand what i mean by that
so she can't get up unless she has her
hands
to get up do you get it so for example
if you're in your your other handcuffing
position you were going to do
go ahead you were going to do it
okay
and uh she can push up on this hand go
ahead and knock her off here do you see
okay um
so that doesn't do anything only it's
breaking the law in california
so we're going to de-post her instead
got it so go back into the position
okay and now i don't want her to put
this hand on the ground
you got it so you gonna make sure this
elbow goes in on this hand
and that you have your two hands here in
place okay
so you'll try to pull that hand on the
ground
not gonna happen okay
and then uh you wanna make sure
that this is down because you're doing
songkill
and this elbow is tight
okay so now you try to pull that hand
down virginia go
got it
then you try to get up now virginia
and she's de-posted so she can't get up
do you get it that's it it's not us
crushing her
it's us d posting her okay so when you
come back
your d posting is this elbow going in
so she can't put her hand on the ground
you got it you don't you don't have to
do an arm bar you just can't let her get
her elbow out
okay
so i'm doing that when i get the cuffs
you feel that virginia she can't get her
elbow out so she can't put the hand down
on the ground okay so that's what you're
doing here
um
you're not trying to do anything you're
just keeping this inside you get it so
you move that over
go ahead here it is move it over and you
don't let that elbow out
okay so when i get the cuffs in place
we'll get there
hold on okay
this
hand
can't let go
because she can't get her elbow up go
ahead get your elbow out
and see she can't get her elbow high
okay and you don't let her elbow out and
we can take our sweet time
and i have two hands to do that okay
which means i can get on the radio too
etc okay so remember you're deposing her
not
using your weight to get them to not
come up okay that's not that's only
relevant to how strong they are and how
heavy you are okay and also how skilled
they are okay all right